in this video i set up a spontaneous
talent show on the streets of cape town
which leads to let's just say some very
interesting auditions
prepare to be amazed
but finally a surprising discovery
hey i'm dan mace i've carried this book
around with me for the past 10 years
it's filled with the most challenging
ideas i've ever had and this show is
dedicated to getting them done
welcome to the brew show
[Music]
six years ago i got this tattoo as well
as wrote this idea down in my ideabook
why cape town will always be home
this is a really meaningful mission for
me because i've lived in sydney los
angeles and new york and i always find
myself returning here back to cape town
this here is cape town this tiny little
area on this entire globe did you know
that over 30 different cultures live
amongst one another in this 2 400 square
kilometer piece of land each cultural
sect has unique heritage and unique
heritage leads to unique talent
therefore there should be a magnitude of
undiscovered talent in cape town but
there's only one way to find out my goal
is to in one day set up this table
with a sign that says cape town's got
talent perform an act and get paid 150
rounds which is 10 us dollars in three
uniquely different areas that have
highly diverse cultural sects one in
langer one in world cup and one on the c
point promenade i'm hoping to find
someone so great that i can offer them a
platform to advance their talent
the time is 7am and i'm on my way to set
up the first talent show of the day in
langa an area like this can be pretty
dangerous so i've reached out to a good
friend of mine bravo
we found the area for the first talent
show perfect
[Music]
we're all the people bruh i don't know i
guess we're gonna have to go and look
for them bravo and i then walked around
langa looking for people keen to join
our talent show
[Music]
we are all set and ready to go i've got
a camera over here a camera over there
it also seems like the word has spread
really quickly because a massive crowd
has arrived at our talent show and bravo
is acting as an usher of some sort but
he seems to be enjoying it a little bit
too much
like one
[Music]
every participant gets ten dollars to do
anything they deem as a talent
where the winner chosen by the crowd
takes home the five hundred dollar cash
prize
ready
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
i see a boy
it seems the crowd has chosen duncan who
is an incredible pansula dancer from
langa to take home the 500 cash prize
what an incredible ending and that was
complete chaos
we are done here in niger and off to the
next location
i'm now headed to sea point on the
promenade which is a reasonably safe
area so i didn't need to reach out to
anyone for help
[Music]
what's this it's a talent show bruh i
may have a talent i can show please
i've had no luck let's do it where do i
do my talents right over there right
over here yeah do i face you
yes perfect
cool so should i just just go for it
prepare to be amazed
okay here we go
i don't know how long to do it for
perfect
thank you bruh i'm amazing thank you
thank you
are you guys here for the talent show
you telling them guys
good to meet you
sasha tell your friends guys
one at a time let's go let's do this
so i'm gonna kick a little freestyle for
you like a lucky three leaf clover when
i rolled over on my eight wheels of
skills i even skate when the hail bear
vibes forever
no
good good vibes
i could feel that
hi there this is [ __ ] panota bowder
[Music]
that was yeah that was something
thank you
[Music]
and for scaring the [ __ ] out of me
christy and her sword took home the 500
cash prize
that was
i am now in burkhart which is arguably
one of the most beautiful places in cape
town with my friend azmed
this area is reasonably safe as long as
you are respectful and have really good
friends like asmed he's gone around and
found local talent for us so this should
be really good
it makes
[Applause]
[Music]
no way
oh my
[Music]
yo
bro
nice one guys it's always okay let your
soul pray you should have faith there
were dark days there were hard ways till
we part ways
that was literally just freestyling yeah
we did we just met oh my gosh
let me get your name oh my gosh as
incredible as the soccer ball
freestylers are it's when i heard the
last act that i had to award more than
just a cash prize
okay the last audition in burkhart the
singer and the rapper they were
incredible so i've called them around to
make a track with jason and i in our
studio and because this wasn't supposed
to be a part of this video i just wanted
to conclude the reason why cape town
will always be home for me it's because
of people like this
it's this melting pot of talent i can
honestly say i would never be the
storyteller i am today if i couldn't
draw inspiration from every single
person in the city i am honored to call
myself a south african even more so a
capetonian let's make some [ __ ] music
let's go
we then spent the day doing what i love
making music
jason who is a brilliantly talented
musician takes all the credit here i
just laid down a few melodies
watching chad and juliet that i only
discovered yesterday's talent shine
through their writing their pitch
perfect voices
their lyrical flow and their ability to
play many instruments and then produce
this track with jason made me realize
again how much undiscovered talent is
out there
[Music]
while signing out this video he has a
snippet of the track as a tease
okay i have linked that track below
please go give it a listen it's amazing
i think it's amazing do you guys think i
think it's epic bro very common be
humble
it is it's really sick and also don't
forget to turn your notifications below
on comment
like
subscribe
and definitely go give this track a
listen it's been an incredible video to
make i never expected this ending other
than that don't forget you're awesome
great and i'll see you next week
thank you for the time thank you for the
reason that i wanna be alive i can
really swim inside can you feel my vibe
everybody rise everybody dies it's the
little things
[Music]
celebrating this life i hope you're
doing it right and if we do it on time
they're gonna see how we shine